peace be with you i Salam alaikum you're
watching the Deen show and my next guest
is going to give us some advice we know
it's very challenging being a Muslim in
today's day and age there's a lot of
temptations the world is tantalizing you
calling you in it's trying to suck the
Iman out of you so how did this young
brother keep focused and how is he able
to do such wonderful things so we're
going to get some tips and tricks from
him
so you guys can stay focused and we can
get the gender together because his
world is short and we don't we don't
want to get sucked in so we right back
with my next guest is a surprise here on
the D show don't go anywhere
[Music]
this is the this is the venue this is
the days mr. Feeny you know this is the
CEO so I'm late going so are you doing
my brother I'm gonna thank you how you
been I'm great
well you've been on my life it's
chilling
you heard me open up the show look time
is short but there are a lot of people
struggling out there you follow me you
know it's it's it's sometimes hard
enough to just to get up you know the
people young kids in the Universities
they're being invited to all these frat
parties you know they're trying to hold
on to their identity now they see
someone like you you're able to hold on
there's hope now at the end of the
tongue there's light now how do you do
it okay to be honest it's very difficult
to do anything alone nowadays right you
have the main problem right now is peer
pressure and friends all right so when
you have friends who are telling you
alright come to this party smoke some
weed do some drugs this and that but on
the other side of the story you have
friends who are telling you don't do
that you need that you need good friends
who will tell you don't go there who
will keep you under you know under
control
because come on let's face it we all
make mistakes well wanna try and that's
the problem with you with the youth
Eddie they want to try they want to be
happy you know they want to go you want
to smoke weed they want to do drugs just
because they want to do you want to feel
happy you know so I feel like we lost
the sense of happiness and that's a
problem with the youth today they're
trying to find happiness and they forget
that true happiness comes from allah
subhanho wa taala
it comes from you know from Reena lantus
be a singing and stuff for Allah and
yeah I guess this is one of the main
problems that we have today at what
point what because everyone has to
people ask me look are you a convert to
Islam look in the sense that that I
convert from not knowing the way of life
to knowing the purpose of I converted
from following the lusts and desires and
just
you know the state of ignorance to the
state of now really knowing what the
purpose of life is you got to make a
conscious decision to be a Muslim right
at what point in your life did you have
did you have a turning point did you
like what point in your life what
happened in your life that had you get
serious well one day my family decided
to take us back to Gaza City right I'm
from Gaza City and when I went there I
lived there for almost ten years and I
realized how blessed we are here in
North America okay
there there are no opportunities in Gaza
City there everyone is so depressed
everyone is sad because of the the
problems that they go through over there
so when I came back here I was like
subhanAllah Sanatana blessed me with a
life you know with opportunities with
with good friends with with that with a
great country where I can practice
freely and where I can you know go out
there I'm safe I'm having fun no
problems whatsoever right so from that
point I was like you know what I need to
change I need to help the community I
want to become a better Muslim
insha'Allah this way I can be thankful
for all the blessings that I have and
it's a problem that here in the West we
don't really see the amount of blessings
that we have and this is why a lot of
people when they go back to the Middle
East or places like Africa they see
poverty they see how tough life is and
how blessed we are they come back and
they become active to become more
religious so this is something that we
are missing today in the West the sister
will deal with the ladies first
you know the guys like look honey you
want Yolo you only live once you know
what I mean why are you wearing that
hijab why are you why you you know
restricting yourself baby come come with
me let's go for a ride what would you
tell the system okay obviously for the
sisters is much more difficult and even
though it's much more difficult for
because she's wearing the hijab she's
wearing the hijab she's she's going
through all these things she needs to
remember that obviously the reward is
much greater for her allah subhanaw
taala is watching okay an allowance
Allah will bless her and the the other
thing when it comes to sisters I would
say is that they they also need to make
sure that they're not fooled by the by
these words especially when it comes to
men like you can come tell a girl some
poetry and tell her you are the son in
my
and you know all this you know nonsense
okay that they don't actually mean you
need to be very careful man because guys
when they get what they want that's it
they're they're out they're gone all
right
but in Islam they're much more precious
women are much more sacred than that and
obviously we need to tell the guys to
fear allah subhanaw taala because
commented into then whatever goes around
comes back around and if they do that to
a sister someone else is going to come
do that to their sister to their mother
or their daughters so we tell the men to
be careful in federal law that's
definitely that is so important because
like you said look the man is usually
out for one thing and he'll have those
sweet words of nothing right but how
have you seen now how expensive now this
the nikah is right and zen has become
cheap what are your comments on it we
actually did a short film about it
called the price of marriage where one
of my friends came to me in real life
and he told me bro I wanted to get
married but the dowry was a hundred
thousand dollars and then we made a
short film about it a hundred thousand
dollars so Han Allah if you're gonna
make the highlight difficult what am I
going to do as a young man I'm gonna go
and do the Haram because the Haram is
easy okay obviously we're not justifying
doing the Haram but at the same time
allah sunnatullah will blame the parents
they will be held accountable for making
it tough for the young man town law and
also that the elders they didn't live in
such a difficult environment within a
hyper sexual an environment where you
find everything you know all these
posters are everywhere so we tell the
parents obviously please put themselves
in the shoes of their kids because it's
everywhere in the school everyone is
doing all this stuff and it's difficult
for them so please you know help them
out in childhood we got some more for
you we'll be right back here on the DS
show don't go anywhere
why don't you want is he not worthy of
praise and thanks I mean think about all
the blessings that we have of Allah he
created you he's the one that feeds you
he's the one that takes care of you the
ability to see one unbelievable blessing
he loves you start fresh today a new
page a new beginning and reach out to
the one who created you asking for
guidance Islamic terrorism misconception
Muslims are terrorists this is by far
the biggest misconception of Islam given
unfairly by stereotyping in the public
image that the media gives has anyone
else noticed how when a specific group
of people attack another group of people
it is labeled as a hate crime but when a
Muslim opens fire on anybody it is
quickly regarded as terrorism many
political dictators and officials or
extremist groups use the name of Islam
as a strategy to garner followers and
attention when many of their practices
go against the true basis of Islam the
media has also portrayed Islam as a cult
or a club where if you join you become a
terrorist and that is now part of your
agenda however all over the world people
practice Islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life there are many
verses in the Quran that go against the
idea of terrorism some of these verses
include fight the way of Allah those
that fight you but do not transgress
limits for God does not love
transgressors this basically means do
not fight except in self-defense and
even in doing so do not go beyond
offense another verse states if they
seek peace then you seek peace which
means do not attack people for no reason
or kill innocent people there is nowhere
in Islam whether it be in the Koran or
the teachings of Muhammad that promotes
the killing of innocent people
please subscribe to the DCO follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show at the mass pikna and
we're witness
Xia Xia you know I'm sorry I chopped up
so many people's names man I messed up
yeah sabotages name came out of nekke
and I finally got it right
I'm les oh excuse me you you're not the
first but definitely won't be the last
but tell me now look what I want to know
is now you did this series also
inspirational series and have a lot of
non Muslims because the idea is that we
want the not yet Muslims those out there
who had there's so many misconceptions
about Islam has it affected them have
you got some feedback from the not yet
Muslims hamdullah you see people are
bored of you know going out there and
preaching ok the prophecy slam did this
and that even though that's the truth
the prophecy Sam did do this and that
prophecy some had the best of manners
but when it's more of a visual material
it does affect people even more so
hamdulillah we had so many people who
actually commented and sentence messages
and said I had no idea that the manners
of the problem analysis um was like this
you know so many people were inspired to
read about Islam and it's amazing to see
that you know there's actually a huge
influence on non-muslims from this
professional you know professional work
and professional projects that's being
you know put together in Charlotte for
the Muslims and non-muslims
alhamdulillah it's been very successful
when it comes to preaching to the
non-muslims now I said ok we'll get to
the brothers we briefly gave some advice
to the sisters and it could be
challenging but you hold down like the
Prophet SAW some said a comic time while
holding on to this Deen will be like
holding on to a hot piece of coal but we
have the great reward of Jenna now you
have some brothers also and they're
looking at the young ladies not lowering
their gaze it affects the saw you
mentioned a world hypersexuality the
society that we live in how about the
brothers now that now are getting
invites every weekend Johnny
Tommy said like men come with me I'll
pay your drink I'll pay the gas money
you don't even have to wait in line I
paid out
bouncer what advice you got for him all
right that's a good deal man okay so
when it comes to lowering your gaze one
thing that we notice that it's becoming
more difficult for sisters to get
married why is that because guys are
getting more picky why is that because
they can't seem to lower their gaze if
they're going and looking everywhere and
looking at you know different posters
and supermodels and all these things
their standards increase and now they
want someone who looks like that that
lady in the poster which is very
difficult because they spent millions on
their bodies on plastic surgeries and
all that stuff so brothers become much
more picky when it comes to choosing a
wife all right so this is why the pelvis
Islam taught us to lower lower our gaze
always lower your gaze because this way
you'll be satisfied and you'll be happy
with whatever I lost panet Allah blesses
you and you'll focus more about the love
the lust panatela is going to bless you
with in trouble oh now some people are
like look Eddie why are you guys talking
about these things you know this is
something that is is prevalent in
today's society you got so much so many
things going on out there that's trying
to take us away from our Deen right the
black spots on the heart the more sins
we do obviously it starts to black in
our hearts and I like to get you know
you're young man you hamdullah laws
blessed you and you're able to hold on
to your Deen we all have struggles I'm
sure you struggling like many of us are
struggling but it's different when it
comes from a young man you like yourself
maybe you know older Shaykh we have
respect for all of our shakes
but sometimes the youth they identify
more with people like yourself now let's
go and transition we jumping around here
and there now you know that there's a
lot of misconceptions about Islam in the
media you did one program with the film
about terrorism right you're on the bus
is that right
tell us a little bit about this for the
non-muslim watching his Muslim friend
got him glued to the straight to the TV
but he's like in his in his mind's like
man those are those al-qaeda guys man
right how do you clear this up
okay obviously the best way to clear
these misconceptions is via good manners
and that's how the process I'm did it is
very cliche for us to hear that you know
what good manners this is how you clear
misconceptions but that's the best way
to do it are we doing it that is a
question when we were filming that scene
of you know clearing misconceptions
about Islam and how you know while
you're walking with your beard and your
throw people start saying all go home
eaters you know you know it's very
typical in the States for it happened
while we were filming there was a guy
who was driving and said go home you
terrorists while we were filming
subhanAllah so um you got a lot of
sisters especially wearing that who were
that job they say I don't know what to
do in school the best way to do it is to
prove the media wrong by your good
manners if they see that you're
following the Prophet Mohammed ISIL
celeb and you're always smiling you're
always nice you never lie do you think
they're going to believe the media
they're not okay so the best way is to
follow the prophets s-salam and to
follow his manners and trust me that
will clear the misconceptions by
themselves we got to take a break don't
go anywhere
we're going to come back for our final
segment here on the D show with our
brother and your brother don't go
anywhere
word can't have defects in it can it if
it is literally God's word yes
it cannot have defects I mean this was
written by men you know that this is a
collection right even if you have
Matthew Mark Luke and John the Gospel
according to according to right the
thing about the Quran and the biggest
and you know I'll leave you with this is
the biggest thing for me is if the Quran
is exactly what it says it is
and this doesn't matter whether you're
Muslim or not if the Quran is what it
says it is the Quran is literally the
Word of God
delivered via Gabriel to Muhammad who
was an unlettered man who couldn't read
or write right he was just told to
recite right that was the first thing
right first thing we recited right so if
it is literally the Word of God then
that's pretty important to me and before
I became Muslim I said if this is the
Word of God then I'm going to follow it
because I'd be stupid not to please
subscribe to the video follow us on our
official Facebook and Twitter pages in
the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and we keep it real
we talk about real issues that are
chasing that are affecting the youth the
Muslims and non-muslims out there and
now companionship we know that birds of
a feather flock together and we have
several hadith and loss want Allah the
Creator observe talks about the
importance of having good companionship
how is that affected you now did you go
through one point maybe having a bad
friend had to give them up and how is it
now you're in a circle making sure that
you have good company that reminds you
about doing good things okay
so humble I'm I made sure that I had a
couple of my friends who I can go up to
and asked I'm alright what do you think
what's your advice and they're real with
me okay and even if they see that I'm
doing a mistake that time all right wake
up buddy what are you doing right so
with that being said obviously there was
a point where I didn't have good friends
and you'll be surprised how friends can
influence you without you noticing okay
you'll be praying five times a day but
these guys you know you're in a group
that doesn't pray they don't really care
and slowly you just start merging into
that group without you realizing and
then after a couple of months you'll be
like wow I changed okay it is because of
the friends and at the same time you
find so many people I'm doing that we
have a good group of friends we bring
slowly like one person one person is not
so religious into the group okay we try
to take him you know let's go out you
have some dinner you know II have a cup
of coffee study together and slowly you
realize that he's changing slowly you
you realize now this guy's Michele
starts to say in sha allah tanah lot
handle asana come guys you know things
that he never used to say before so I
just wanna the one point that I would
send is that don't underestimate it
because it is influencing you even if
you think it's not absolutely look I
know for myself that when I got to know
Islam the more you study Islam the more
you're convinced on it because it's
based on proof and evidence and it's
something that is the natural way but
one thing now after the person makes
that declaration that there's nothing
where they worship except my maker
I'm not going to worship anything in
creation but the one who made me and
then you hook up with a lot of five
times a day you dial up directly with
the salat that saved me it definitely
you know being conscious of your maker
that perfect system how important is
that for a Muslim now and how has that
impacted your life be holding on to the
Salah the prayer how like just the fact
that the profitsystem taught us that
between each Salah all the sins that you
do in between each Salah are forgiven
that should be enough reason for you to
pray five times a day stronger when it
comes to that we obviously need to take
care of our bodies physically and
spiritually okay it's like a medicine
people need to realize that it's like a
medicine for you to go put your head on
the ground and pay to Allah so Hannah
Thailand the province of Sam taught us
that if people knew the azure that they
are getting well their head their
foreheads on the ground they would never
get up subhanAllah so we need we need to
enhance Allah told us women are Adan
dick - ll - Don Blanca
whoever neglects my dick here test B
Apple and prayer I was gonna give him a
miserable life ok it a lot of promise
they's gonna give you a miserable life
if you don't do it and do you think that
Allah has promised is gonna go for waste
panel up it's not philosophy sin the
Quran is gonna happen so if you're
fishing for happiness you're going after
drugs you're gonna have to weed
alright and you don't pray yeah yeah
there's a problem okay then there's a
problem obviously trying to find
happiness when I lost hunt Allah that
told you that happiness is when you put
your forehead to the ground Allah is
telling you so don't come and ask me
where is happiness
when a lust hunt Allah is telling you
put your head to the ground you'll find
happiness obviously we're not talking
about the diseases of depression and
anxiety as a different thing but I'm
talking about people who you know who
complain a lot about happiness when it's
right in front of them panel allows
hunters given to us thank you so much
for being with us on the Deen show we
started with peace we and with peace and
I hear inshallah you're gonna be in
Chicago sometime in shell and chela
we're gonna be I'm put you on spot you
can be maybe my student training Gracie
jiu-jitsu it would be a pleasure let's
do it beautiful let's do it thank you so
much these a client's long liquor and
there you have it all the struggles that
you might be going through others have
gone through it but you know when you
struggle and strive in the way of your
Creator there's an ultimate reward
waiting for you Jenna and it's not cheap
you got to work now hard so if you have
any problems stop and drop and connect
with your maker and ask him for the help
and he will definitely send that help so
subscribe if you haven't and continue to
tune in every week to the D show until
then peace be with you so long like
please subscribe to the D show follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]